what's the meaning of this whole thing
the robin meaning of life what is the
meaning of life
we talked about alien civilizations
but this is the one we got where are the
aliens we are the human
seem to be
conscious be able to introspect
what's why why why are we here this is
the thing i told you before about how we
can predict that future creatures will
be different from us
we
our preferences are this amalgam of
various sorts of random sort of
patched-together
preferences about thirst and sex and
sleep and attention and all these sorts
of things so
we don't understand that very well it's
not very transparent and it's a mess
right
that is the source of our motivation
that is how we were made and how we are
induced to do things but we can't
summarize it very well and we don't even
understand it very well
that's who we are and often we find
ourselves in a situation where we don't
feel very motivated we don't know why in
other situations we find ourselves very
motivated and we don't know why either
and so that's the nature of being a
human of the sort that we are because
even though we can think abstractly and
reason abstractly this package of
motivations is just opaque and a mess
and that's what it means to be a human
today and the motivation we we can't
very well tell the meaning of our life
it is this mess that our descendants
will be different they will actually
know exactly what they want
and it will be to have more descendants
for that will be the meaning for them
well it's funny that you have the
certainty you have more certainty you
have more transparency about our
descendants than you do about your own
self right so
um
it's really interesting to think because
you mentioned this about love
that
something
that's fundamental about love is this
opaqueness that we're not able to really
introspect what the heck it is
um
or all the feelings the complex feelings
involved true about many of our
motivations and that's what it means to
be human of the 20
20th and the 21st century variety
um why is that not a feature that we
want
will choose to persist in civilization
then this opaqueness you know put
another way
mystery maintaining a sense of mystery
about ourselves and about those around
us
uh maybe that's a really nice thing to
have
maybe but so i mean this is the
fundamental issue and
analyzing the future what will set the
future
one theory about what will set the
future is
what do we want the future to be
so under that theory we should sit and
talk about what we went to future we
have some conferences have some
conventions you know discussion things
vote on it maybe and then hand it off to
the implementation people to make the
future the way we've decided it should
be
that's not the actual process that's
changed the world over history up to
this point it has not been the result of
us deciding what we want and making it
happen
in our individual lives we can do that
and we might decide what career we want
or where we want to live who we want to
live with in our individual lives we
often do
slowly make our lives better according
to our plan and our things but that's
not the whole world
the whole world so far has mostly been a
competitive world where things happen if
anybody anywhere chooses to adopt them
and they have an advantage and then it
spreads and other people are forced to
adopt it by competitive pressures
so that's the kind of analysis i can use
to predict the future and i do use that
to predict the future it doesn't tell us
it'll be a feature we like it just tells
us what it'll be
and it'll be one where we're trying to
maximize the number of our descendants
and we know that abstractly indirectly
and it's not opaque with some
probability that's non-zero that will
lead us to become grabby
in
expanding
aggressively out into the cosmos until
we meet other aliens the timing isn't
clear we might become glabby and then
this happens these are
grabbing us in this are both the results
of competition but it's less clear which
happens first
does this future excite you or scare you
how you feel about this well i think
again i told you compared to sort of a
dead cosmology at least it it's
energizing and having a living story
with real actors and characters and
agendas right
yeah and that's one one hell of a fun
universe to live in robin you're one of
the most fascinating fun people to talk
to brilliant
humble
systematic in your analysis hold on to
my wallet here what's he looking for i
already stole your wallet long ago i
really really appreciate you spend your
valuable time with me i hope you get a
chance to talk
many more times in the future thank you
so much for sitting down thank you
you